c'est un réquisitoire exemplaire les
avocats généraux ont estimé que la
plupart des accusés avaient connaissance
des intentions terroristes dames et 10
coulibaly alors sans surprise la
perpétuité a été requise contre le
principal accusé ali riza pollack pour
les autres de 5 à 7 ans ont été requis à
l'encontre des prévenus contre lesquels
les charges d' association de
malfaiteurs terroristes ont été
abandonnées de 13 à 20 ans étaient
requis pour les proches de mehdi
coulibaly et de 15 à 18 ans pour les
trafiquants d'armes présumé même s'il
connaissait pour certains à peine
amedick coulibaly un réquisitoire jugée
sévère par la défense qui pensent que
leur client ne sont que des seconds
couteaux je vous propose d'écouter
l'avocat de médecine carassou leur un
garagiste belge qui a vendu une voiture
pour amedi coulibaly possiblement des
armes
je suis effectivement très surpris par
la sévérité des réquisitions
je le disais tout à l'heure en une demi
heure
le parquet a demandé plus de deux
siècles de prison
plus de deux siècles et tout le monde
est surpris par la sévérité
parce que s'il y en a qui méritent des
peines un peu plus haute
d'autres méritent d'avoir des peines
plus basse et notamment mon client que
monsieur carasso l'art qui manifestement
n'a jamais mis les pieds en france qui a
été impliqué dans cette affaire pour
vendre une voiture alors que c'est on
est venu chez lui pour qu'il donne de
l'argent alors que c'est même pas lui
qui a vendu la voiture c'est monsieur
stasi qui l'a vendue en grèce et qui n'a
même pas été impliqué dans la sphère et
lui il se retrouve avec quinze ans ce
c'est incompréhensible
les avocats du principal accusé ali reza
paul at on plaidé cet après midi pour
mettre coûtant peyre on ne sait par
exemple pas occupée des principaux
fournisseurs d'armes en effet à mehdi
coulibaly a utilisé des armes qui
provenait d'une filière lilloise elle
était gérée par un identitaire français
également indiqué or celui ci a bien été
jugé mais dans le cadre d'une autre
affaire à lille il a été condamné une
faible peine pour cela cela a de quoi
étonner dans la
mesure où les autres fournisseurs
d'armes se retrouve bien dans ce procès
là autres arguments développés par la
défense si elle y paulette avait connu
les intentions d'un médicaux les valley
pourquoi n'est-il pas partie tout comme
hayat boumédiène ou encore les frères
belhocine quelques jours avant les
attentats
voilà des arguments développés par la
défense pour tenter d'infléchir la cour